alors régime vous avez vidéo vous avez
eu des bas on va vous faire une
interview à peine down c'est normal
régine ce que vous préférez en vous y
accolant de mes cheveux
bien egin ce que vous haïssez en vous un
coffre-fort d'une fois les jeans que
vous préférez dans la nuit le petit
matin ce que vous détestez dans la nuit
les imbéciles qui viennent le plus grand
moment de votre vie
les plus grands moments de ma vie c'est
la maison de ma petite fille
le pire moment le pire moment c'est
quand effectivement claude a été arrêté
votre plus gros coup de fric c'était
très longue
pendant 25 ans hu est votre plus grosse
perte
pendant ces 25 ans si j'ai tout jeté par
les fenêtres mais lâche très généreuse
vous savez quand vous voyez des crédits
composer des repas chez vous au dessus
du new jimmy'z vouloir faisait des
boulettes polonais ça coûterait pas très
cher ça quand même
non ça non mais quand je faisais aussi
caviar violon et agios chez accor payer
des agios avec la crédibilité souvent
dans le rouge
et quand j'étais très ami avec beaucoup
de banquiers je pensais qu'il ait pas
d'agios torchet parce que ça ne valait
même pas comment ça s'écrit avec
l'accord j'ai vite appris votre plus
belle histoire d'amour régime c'est
toujours la première clause oui ça vous
a marqué celui qui vous avez pu souffler
magnéto serge absolument
étaient présents avant si ce que je vois
à peu près l'âge où on se fait des puces
lit maintenant voilà que l'âge 13 ans et
demi ça s'est bien passé c'était plutôt
désagréable ouais quand les bois non
mais c'est vrai révélé c'est tout ce
week-end bien sûr bien alors votre plus
minables histoire d'amour et gênes 1
écoutez franchement j'ai pas eu
d'histoires d'amour du n'a pas bon non
maintenant j'ai eu des grands histoire
avec des gens alors oui formidable
trilogie
vous avez été avec el cordobès oui et
puis encore de la baisse pendant deux
ans à la fin petit matin dans les
oreilles et la queue comme non on était
toujours en train de faire la bourse
allé très très bien voilà
régine ce que vous avez de plus section
la voix de moins sexy mon caractère
régine ce que vous préférez dans le sexe
après cantons riches à henry après ça si
vous riez pas c'est le baiser malheur
et qui vous dégoûte dans le sac fragile
à part le groupe bien sûr